there was a movie we had out this summer
called Captain America Civil War the
people okay good good the characters in
that movie you know some of them go into
other movies some of them have come from
other movies one of them was introduced
for the very first time in that movie
and his name was Black Panther he's and
gentlemen the director of Black Panther
Ryan Coogler the co-writer Joe Robert
Cole and myself really trying to make
something that you guys can really enjoy
um about the world of a condor um but we
all know what's the coolest part about
the world of Wakanda that's the fact
they have a king a warrior king that
takes care of that protection and he's
here right now
being being here at Comic Con this is my
first time here right he did I can
literally feel it vibrating inside
inside my core it is amazing it is
amazing thank you so much for just
giving giving back what we give to you
is it's incredible it's a lot I can say
over over the past couple of months
after the movie has come out the glimpse
into the character and into what Conda
has been a beautiful beautiful thing for
me thank you for everything that I've
heard from the fans about the character
and about what you hope to see in Black
Panther I cannot wait to amass more of
it for you all right and Bryan has had
some beautiful things in store for us
and Ryan I think I think some other
friends came along to the pizza and
yong-go is
we got a adversary I Black Panther have
the face a Marik kill monger play by
Michael B Jordan and last but definitely
not least the head of the door of my
Lodge a character named or coy yay oh I
can't wait for you guys to meet play
about it the amazing actress Danai
gurira
I know you guys haven't really started
anything yet I know you have to get back
and start shooting but is there anything
you can tell us how do you guys feel
about joining this amazing experience
and cast and working with Ryan I'm
extremely excited to be a part of this
cast working with my fantastic director
again incredible cast and a new world
and a new character kind of sorts of to
portray so I'm extremely excited I wish
I could tell you guys more I don't even
know Ryan's been uh keeping it under
wraps pretty pretty pretty good so uh
next time hopefully we'll have a lot
more to say and the P tag do you have
anything you know anything you're
excited about about taking on a role
like this and getting into the superhero
universe well first of all it's my first
time at comic-con - Wow
thank you for the very warm welcome I am
looking forward to kicking some ass it's
not my first time my comic-con not my
first time in Hall H I love y'all
I'm still pinching myself I cannot
believe I'm up here with these
astounding people I just finished
working this beautiful woman that
amazing man over there this filmmaker is
I've respected and admired for so long
as well as these two astounding actors
so to sit down with mr. cooler and learn
his vision has been I'm just
utterly pinching myself to see this come
to life and to be a part of it I still
kind of can't believe I'm standing here
this is a really really emotional for me
man I'm I don't know if you guys know
this Brahma uh big big comic book fan in
2009 I went to my first comic-con I sat
way way way way way back there so it's
so it's absolutely crazy to be looking
at my people from this view you know me
hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel
dropped a whole bunch of Black Panther
movies stuff at Comic Con so there's
going to be a breakdown of that so one
of the biggest things is they revealed
Danai gurira the person who plays
Michonne from The Walking Dead is going
to be the leader of the Dora mill Jay in
the movie is gonna have this really
interesting relationship with Lupita
Nyong'o who's playing something of a
villain character not outright villain
but somewhat of an antagonist in the
film who's also Dora mill gee if you
don't know who the door and Bill J are
they were basically these figures during
Captain America's Civil War
they're like the personal honor guard of
Black Panther you know he kind of
chuckled when one of them told Black
Widow to get the hell out of the way
he's like Oh as entertaining as that
would be to see the two of them fight we
have to get going so he was kind of
acknowledging how badass they are but
they really brushed over it during
Captain America Civil War you'll really
see how badass they are during Black
Panther so definitely going to be
throwing down in that movie but the
story they revealed is the story of two
enemies of Black Panther coming together
to threaten his leadership so one of
those is going to be Eric kill monger
played by Michael B Jordans character
he's a pretty standard Black Panther
villain the other one is secret but it's
probably going to end up being ulysses
klaw like they didn't reveal who the
second villain of this big villain
team-up of the Black Panther movie was
but I'm guessing because ulysses klaw
talked about Wakanda in past tense
during Avengers age of Ultron he's going
to come roaring back because now he has
billions of dollars that Ultron paid him
for that vibranium so we might get to
see ulysses klaw with the actual cloth
from the comics also if you didn't know
something that's really cool Ryan
Coogler is the director now Michael B
Jordan like I said is one of the main
villains of the film he was the lead of
the Creed movie that was directed by
Ryan Coogler that's kind of what got
Ryan Coogler the black panther job so
the movie is supposed to premiere
February 2018 so it's a ways off they
haven't started to shoot yet but they
will pretty soon so they'll have a lot
of behind the scenes stuff like you know
they've been doing behind the scenes
stuff for thor ragnarok they've been
dropping stuff from the movies in
production which is actually really cool
they don't have to do a lot of times
they don't wait till movies are done to
release the trailer but they're so
confident about how awesome they're
they're like hey look you know we just
been shooting for a couple days look at
some of the stuff they're doing behind
the scenes so just like Mark Ruffalo
is teasing Hulk stuff during thor
ragnarok expect them to start teasing
black panther stuff when they shoot that
movie and i know a lot of you're
wondering will Winter Soldier come back
during the Black Panther movie will he
appear in some way because Captain
America pretty much left him in a
wakandan safety deposit box so even if
they don't bring him back in a big way I
think they'll still reference what's
going on so you'll see some kind of
Winter Soldier Easter egg even if they
don't unlock sickle so because it's in
February Black Panther is the last movie
before Avengers infinity war so if
there's still a gem that's left to be
found before that starts then that's
where it's gonna appear James Gunn
actually just came out and said there's
going to be no infinity gem in guardians
of the galaxy volume 2 so I think that
we will see the time gem during Doctor
Strange leaving the soul gem up for
grabs neither thor ragnarok or black
panther because those are the only other
two movies before infinity war so keep
your eyes peeled for gems I was actually
really happy that James Gunn did that he
doesn't have to he revealed star Lord's
father and he revealed no infinity gems
no Thanos in his movie so for those that
are asking Spider Man footage guardians
of the galaxy footage probably going to
be dropping around the same time later
this year when Doctor Strange actually
does hit theaters so because spider-man
homecoming is dropping before Thor
Ragnarok a lot before like spider-man
homecoming is dropping during the summer
next year
Thor's going to be another November
movie I'm expecting spider-man footage
to drop first so it's going to be really
exciting it'll probably be a virgin like
a more polished version of the footage
they showed off at Comic Con I've
already done a breakdown of all the
Comic Con footage they show enough for
all the movies so I'll put links for
that in the description but usually when
they release full trailers it ends up
being weight you know way more footage
or just way more polished versions of
Comic Con footage so if you have any
requests for other Comic Con stuff that
I haven't done videos for yet just let
me know in the comments be sure to
subscribe to get everything and for
those that are asking if you want to get
ready for Black Panther there's a number
of versions of the origin story that
have been told in the comics there was
another version of the origin story
around 2004-2005 you can read that
although I think the current run is
actually more well written and a little
more geared towards what's going on in
the Marvel Universe right now so like
the all-new all-different black panther
like the brand new title they just
started running
that's probably the best thing to read
just to get a sense for what's going on
in Wakanda like the actual day-to-day of
what it's like in Wakanda which is
basically what the Black Panther movie
is going to tell you but you've seen the
badass now you get to learn where he
comes from and get a real sense for how
he fits in to the larger Marvel Universe
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you could click here for my
breakdown of all the Marvel trailers
from Doctor Strange to spider-man Home
Coming guardians of the galaxy you can
click here for my breakdown of the
Justice League trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you